wenn man sich diese pressekonferenz
angehört hat dann hat man fast ein
bisschen das gefühl dass es diese
großartige errungenschaft eines
impfstoffs innerhalb eines jahres
entwickelt wurde
das wird von der politik auch immer
wieder betont als gäbe es die überhaupt
nicht wir haben da eine pressekonferenz
aus einer anderen zeit erlebt wir sind
mit einer zeitmaschine in das in die
zeit vor dem impfstoff gereist und haben
die methoden und die sprache und die
logik von vor dem impfstoff gehört die
länder die impfen sprechen diese sprache
die bundeskanzlerin angela merkel das
spricht nicht mehr da geht es nicht mehr
um den erwerb und die nächste welle die
droht und das infektionsgeschehen und ob
man vielleicht auch wieder zu machen
muss ja da ist noch einiges geschlossen
aber die perspektive ist klar israel ist
auf der zielgeraden
in amerika öffnen am 14 februar am
valentinstag die restaurants amerika 40
millionen menschen geimpft in england
wird eine halbe million menschen am tag
gibt dort gibt es hoffnung und dort gibt
es ein neues thema dort gibt es eine
neue herangehensweise an die pandemie
nämlich das einzige was dieser pandemie
den garaus machen kann der impfstoff und
davon war hier einfach überhaupt keine
rede wir haben dort eine pressekonferenz
erlebt hier hätten wir genauso gut im
juli 2020 uns anhören können und es
zeigt doch dass das einzige mittel was
im moment da ist das mittel ist was es
eben vor dem hilfsstoff gab und was ich
ganz besonders bemerkenswert fand es
diese logik dass wir uns jetzt mit dem
lockdown mit einem weiter brutal harten
lockdown die menschen kaputt macht wie
malu dreyer sagt unter die 35 zwingen
wollen um dann vorsichtig aufzumachen
ich frage mich wie soll es denn dann bei
unter 35 bleiben wenn wir diesen harten
lockdown brauchen und keinen impfstoff
haben und jetzt ist die logik wir müssen
den locker und im zweiten lockdown
verlängern damit der dritte lockdown
licht kommt das erinnert mich an einen
satz aus dem vietnamkrieg wo es hieß wir
mussten die stadt zerstören um sie zu
retten das ist ein bisschen die politik
unserer bundesregierung ohne impfstoff
gerade julian du kannst auch den
bayerischen ministerpräsidenten markus
söder gut er hat gesagt wir müssen
vorsichtig sein vorsichtig bleiben die
vorsichtig kite hat sich durchgesetzt
wie
lebst du söder in dieser situation weil
er jemand ist der eigentlich genauso wie
die kanzlerin eben für diesen massiv
vorsichtigen kurs steht der auch beim
thema schulen sogar sehr zurückhaltend
war und da der kanzlerin immer
zugestimmt hat und hat gesagt ja ja ist
es richtig dass wir da noch warten wegen
der mutation was hörst du da von ihm was
hörst aus seinem umfeld wie man
eigentlich in die zukunft kommen will
denn wenn man sich sehr nachbarland
österreich anschaut jetzt kann man sagen
okay das wird wieder geschlossen werden
denn drei oder vier wochen aber
zumindest haben wir es jetzt mal
versucht und das ja durchaus druck der
auf ihm lastet oder markus söder ist
daher glaube ich ein bisschen
zwiegespalten er ist einerseits
politisch seit einem jahr extrem
erfolgreich mit seinem kurs der
konsequenz in einem ausmaß erfolgreich
das ihm eine chance auf die
kanzlerkandidatur beschert in einem
ausmaß erfolgreich dass er zu dem
schluss gekommen ist konsequent sein
hilft ihm in den umfragen mehr als
vielleicht dem den wechselnden
stimmungen zu folgen konsequenz wird in
der krise wertgeschätzt
deswegen bleibt dabei seinen kurz
gleichzeitig das weiß ich aus vielen
persönlichen gesprächen da warte ich
aber auch keine großen geheimnisse denn
das wissen wir auch aus interviews weiß
auch markus söder
es gibt nur einen einzigen grund warum
wir der zeit diese sprache und diese
debatte führen
die eu hat zu wenig impfstoff für europa
um für deutschland bestellt die
bundeskanzlerin hat ein verfahren
veranlasst das komplett und krachend
gescheitert ist du hast heute mit elise
drüber gesprochen wir hören es ja es
werden auch keine fragen mehr zum
impfstoff beantwortet die
verantwortlichen möchten auch nicht mehr
darüber sprechen die verantwortlichen
seien moment moment moment im
vorgespräch haben wir aber gesagt es
gibt keine fragen zum impfstoff
man möchte nicht mehr über das thema
impfstoff sprechen weil es beschämend
ist und weil es menschen in das hinein
zwingt was wie malu dreyer war es glaube
ich heute gesagt die menschen kaputt
macht das was dort moment passiert das
mag notwendig sein ich kann das nicht
beurteilen
dafür bin ich nicht der virologe oder
epidemiologe das mag notwendig sein ich
kann es nicht beurteilen aber es wäre
nicht notwendig wenn es genügend
impfstoff gebe dann hätten wir eine
andere perspektive
deswegen muss man ganz klar sagen die
debatten die da heute geführt worden
sind sind nicht das ergebnis einer
katastrophe wie es uns immer verkauft
wird sie sind das ergebnis von
politischem management versagen beim
thema lass uns da man einmal ganz kurz
bleiben julian weil neben der tatsache
dass eben dieses impfstoff versagen so
kolossales und bild das ja auch immer
wieder anfragen hat was da passiert ist
in brüssel und berlin
die menschen aber jetzt verstanden dass
es schief gegangen und das kann man auch
nicht mehr ausgleichen weil die
produktion wird so lange dauern dass man
das nicht mehr aufholen kann zumindest
im vergleich zu großbritannien und
israel
wenn wir jetzt von dem zustand ausgehen
und einmal die frage aufwerfen welche
alternativen haben wir vor dem
hintergrund dass wir zu wenig impfstoff
haben die fdp zum beispiel sagt wir
könnten trotzdem irgendwie öffnen die
kritiker sagen nein das geht auf gar
keinen fall weil da gibt's die
südafrikanische mutante da gibt es die
mutter aus großbritannien gleichzeitig
sehen wir aber an anderen europäischen
ländern wo es auch zu wenig impfstoff
gibt das zumindest schritte unternommen
werden wobei man auch sagen muss
insbesondere in österreich kann ich
sagen ist man da sehr vorsichtig was
großem optimismus angeht dass man das
durchhält auf dauer
was glaubst du wäre denn möglich trotz
dieses kolossalen scheiterns beim
impfstoff in einer öffnung strategie
oder bei der frage was wir jetzt öffnen
könnten ich glaube was wir heute doch
gespürt haben wenn das so weitergeht wie
es auf dieser pressekonferenz verkündet
wurde und der kleinen schlenker sein wir
kurz erlaubt man hat ja das gefühl der
befinden sich einige herrschaften ihrer
komplett eigenen welt bürgermeister
regierende bürgermeister von berlin
herr müller der eine dysfunktion ersten
großstädte in unserem wundervollen land
regiert erzählte eine schwärmerische
geschichte über den erfolgskurs wie
teuer er so glücklich und freut sich
dass der erfolgskurs funktioniert hat
während die im pflaster leer sind die
impfzentren leer sind und ist ja
keinerlei erkennbare perspektiven er
sagt wir haben menschenleben gerettet
durch unsere maßnahmen ein es sind
menschen gestorben weil es keinen
impfstoff gibt das ist die realität
und da komme ich zu meinem eigentlichen
punkt die selbstzufriedenheit mit der
dort ein historisches versagen
schöngeredet wird die wird natürlich
nicht dazu führen
dass man zu mehr ambitionierten lösungen
kommt ich würde mich nicht damit
zufrieden geben dass man das mit dem
impfstoff jetzt nicht mehr ändern kann
jetzt hat ein werk von von beyond
glücklicherweise ja großartige menschen
großartigen unternehmer großartiger
erfinder großartige wissenschaftler gut
dass dieses werk und heute eröffnet aber
der anspruch unserer bundesregierung
müsste doch seien wir bauen jetzt 20
werke welche fabrik kann produziert um
impfstoff zu schaffen wir können doch
jetzt nicht sagen na ja es gibt halt
nicht genug ein ganz interessanter punkt
eben bei bundeskanzlerin angela merkel
und ich hoffe sie hat sich da einfach
nur falsch ausgedrückt ich befürchte
aber sie hat sich einfach verplappert
sie hat gesagt bei den lehrern
wir werden irgendwann im sommer
hoffentlich anfangen die gruppe 2 zu
impfen
das ist das was sie eben gesagt hat wenn
sie das so gemeint hat heißt das aber
dass das ganze in versprechen wir werden
bis ende des sommers allen deutschen ein
angebot gemacht haben sechs gruppen und
den optimismus hat man auch gestrichen
ganz kurz nach also den optimismus hat
gehört unser angebot also wenn angela
merkel sich nicht wenn angela merkel ist
nicht versprochen sondern verplappert
hat dann hat sie das im versprechen was
sie gegeben hat da gerade passiert das
wenn wir anfang des sommers gruppe 2 1
kinder gibt es kein um versprechen und
wenn wir der tonalität und den worten
dieser pressekonferenz folgen dann
wissen wir doch alle
wenn wir ende des jahres im november
vielleicht mal wieder ins blockhaus
dürfen auf eine ofenkartoffel dann haben
wir noch glück gehabt ja das ist der
stand den wir gerade sehen und das
schlimme ist damit gibt sich die politik
gerade zufrieden und er müller erzählt
als als würden wir alle glückselig auf
den straßen tanzen weil seine strategie
so gut aufgegangen ist die menschen
sitzen zunehmend depressiv zu hause und
würden sich von ihrer regierung an dass
das ein erfolgsweg ist aber nochmal
julian noch mal ganz kurz weil weil wir
müssen gleich auch weiter zu zu peter
thiede
aber was glaubst du also du sagst zum
einen wir müssen da noch mal hart an die
produktion haben wir müssen alles
versuchen da viel impfstoff auf den weg
zu bekommen
absolut beide aber was was kann man aus
deiner sicht und auch wie du die
politische lage sozusagen in deutschland
analysiert und siehst du mit mir
bespricht was kann man trotz dieser
impfstoff
jetzt öffnen und wie siehst du die
debatte um die residenz wert ich halte
die debatte um diese instanz wert für
entschuldigung für extrem überfallartig
damit hatte nun wirklich keiner
gerechnet dass wenn wir jetzt irgendwann
mal auf 35 kommen mal wieder zwei leute
in der douglas prinzip dürfen
ich finde das hätte man schon etwas
transparent da vorher machen können dass
man diesen 50 er wird jetzt auf 35 senkt
zu deiner frage ich glaube wir haben es
doch heute alle gespürt wir sind in
einer situation in der wir entweder
möglichkeiten finden mit dieser
bedrohung ja mit diesem risiko zu leben
oder wir leben dieses jahr auf jeden
fall genauso weiter wie heute vielleicht
können wir im sommer mal offenbar kommen
und uns ein bisschen freuen
aber wir werden dann so weiterleben es
gibt im moment keinerlei perspektive
deswegen glaube ich ja wir brauchen
versuche mit dem risiko zu leben so wie
menschen das immer getan habe und es
gibt einen ganz entscheidenden punkt und
auch der hat heute wieder keine rolle
gespielt man kann die risikogruppen
schützen
man kann die menschen schützen die davon
am meisten betroffen sind
man könnte sie auch impfen können da wir
leider keinen impfstoff haben sollte man
jetzt alles tun sie zu schützen und wenn
davon selbsttests gesprochen wird die
gibt es seit einem jahr seit einem jahr
seit einem jahr wenn sie nicht
ausgeliefert sie werden nicht angewandt
natürlich kann man die risikogruppen
besonders welche in den altenheimen
schützen
mehr noch wer masken zur verfügung
stellt man könnte dafür sorgen dass die
die todeszahlen dramatisch sinken indem
man ja wohl auch bei bild oft darüber
berichtet vor besonderen ins einrichtung
die altenheim die bundeswehr einsetzt
und nicht noch einmal auf einen antrag
wartet dass die damaligen stäbchen in
die nase stecken dürfen
all das geschieht nicht uns werden die
rezepte reserviert von aus dem ersten
block da aus dem april
danach wurde uns gesagt mit dem wissen
von heute würde man das nicht mehr tun
und jetzt mit dem wissen von heute macht
man es noch viel schlimmer und hat
keinerlei ambitionen daran irgendetwas
zu ändern oder die produktion dieses
gewaltigen wirtschaftsstandorts
deutschland auf das umzustellen was der
einzige ausweg ist nämlich impfstoff
impfstoff impfstoff impfstoff mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dich hier das nächste video
an und vergisst nichts